the story of the billy possum was all wrong,
especially compared
to the backstory of the teddy bear.
Think about it: for most of human's evolutionary history,
what's made bears impressive to us
has been their complete independence from us.
It's that they live these parallel lives
as menaces and competitors.
By the time Roosevelt went hunting in Mississippi,
that stature was being crushed,
and the animal that he had roped to a tree
really was a symbol for all bears.
Whether those animals lived or died now
was entirely up to the compassion
or the indifference of people.
That said something really ominous
about the future of bears,
but it also said something very unsettling about who we'd become,
if the survival of even an animal like that
was up to us now.
So now, a century later, if you're at all
paying attention to what's happening in the environment,
you feel that discomfort so much more intensely.
We're living now in an age of what scientists
have started to call "conservation reliance,"
and what that term means is that we've disrupted
so much that nature can't possibly stand on its own anymore,
and most endangered species
are only going to survive
if we stay out there in the landscape
riggging the world around them in their favor.
So we've gone hands-on
and we can't ever take our hands off,
and that's a hell of a lot of work.
Right now, we're training condors
not to perch on power lines.
We teach whooping cranes to migrate south for the winter
behind little ultra-light airplanes.
We're out there feeding plague vaccine to ferrets.
We monitor pygmy rabbits with drones.
So we've gone from annihilating species
to micromanaging the survival of a lot of species
indefinitely, and which ones?
Well, the ones that we've told
compelling stories about,
the ones we've decided ought to stick around.
The line between conservation and domestication
is blurred.
So what I've been saying is that the stories
that we tell about wild animals are so subjective
they can be irrational
or romanticized or sensationalized.
Sometimes they just have nothing to do with the facts.
But in a world of conservation reliance,
those stories have very real consequences,
because now, how we feel about an animal
affects its survival
more than anything that you read about
in ecology textbooks.
Storytelling matters now.
Emotion matters.
Our imagination has become an ecological force.
And so maybe the teddy bear worked in part
because the legend of Roosevelt
and that bear in Mississippi
was kind of like an allegory
of this great responsibility that society
was just beginning to face up to back then.
It would be another 71 years
before the Endangered Species Act was passed,
but really, here's its whole ethos
boiled down into something like a scene
you'd see in a stained glass window.
The bear is a helpless victim tied to a tree,
and the president of the United States
decided to show it some mercy.
Thank you.
(Applause)
[Illustrations by Wendy MacNaughton]